- How do you even open it?
Ohh.
(upbeat music)
- I've held them a bunch.
Namely waiting for other people
to finish what they're doing.
- I feel like I should
be somewhat accustomed
to knowing what purse is more expensive
based on the hours that I
spend watching my family
shop for purses.
- The brands are covered so my initial way
of determining what's more
expensive is off the table.
- My first thought is that
both of these are really ugly.
- Somebody told me, look
out for the zippers.
So maybe this is the key.
- You can tell how expensive
something is by the lining.
The material seems kind of like synthetic.
- I'm just gonna massage the
interior of both of these.
- Inside kinda looks
like a really cheap suit.
- This looks like something that like
happened in the Cadillac in the 80s.
- I think this is
the more expensive one.
(bell rings)
- Based on the lining,
this is more expensive
than this one.
(bell ringing)
- I would guess that this
one is more expensive.
(bell rings)
- I'm going with this one.
- [Woman Behind Camera] You're right.
- Yes.
- This purse is atrocious.
- This one's got this
nice cow feature on it.
- Is it a cow and a dalmatian had a baby?
- Or is it dalmatian, I don't know.
This is Cruella de Vil's purse.
- My eyes' drawn to the leopard print.
- Kinda feels like a suitcase
which is not okay with me.
- This smells like T.J. Maxx.
- This is like, I'm going out
but I don't need that much.
It's just going to be me tonight.
- This is probably the
kind of purse I would wear.
- It looks like something
my mom maybe had in 1987.
- This feels like more of
a regular, every day bag
but the leather feels a lot nicer.
- It feels and smells like real leather.
This feels so gross and fake
that if this is more expensive
I'm gonna revolt.
- I'm gonna go this one,
more expensive.
(beeper buzzes)
- I think this costs more.
- I think this
is the more expensive one.
(beeper buzzes)
- This is more expensive, right?
- [Woman Behind Camera] Nope.
- This is more expensive?
What the (beep)?
This is one of the worse
purses I've ever seen.
- This is not a purse.
- Is this actually a purse?
What do you put in ...
How do you open it?
- Oh, you just push it.
Oh, it's a button, just push it.
- So, I know that this is a clutch.
For a dragon lady.
- This looks like something
that Indiana Jones
would recover from a cave.
- This is just really uncomfortable,
so probably more expensive.
- If this didn't have a
strap would it be a clutch
or would it just be a paperweight?
- Now there's this thing.
It's very rectangular.
- I quite like this purse.
This would make a good couch.
Yeah.
In the 1980s, a special edition boom box
might come in this carrying case.
- You know, I'm gonna go with the smaller,
the more expensive, I'm
gonna say the clutch
is more expensive.
(bell ringing)
- I'm gonna go with this one.
(beeper buzzes)
- They're both in absurd
shapes that I wouldn't want
to carry around ever.
And I think this one costs more.
(beeper buzzes)
- I'm gonna go on a limb and
say this is the expensive one.
(bell ringing)
- [Woman Behind Camera] You're right.
- Yes.
- Truly no body is buying
this to actually use it,
so it's just like a
Beanie Baby at this point.
- I'm gonna work really
hard and then spend it
on an empty thing.
It's literally an empty thing.
It's an empty purchase.
You could go anywhere in the world
for what one of these purses cost.
- If I was a woman, I
know I would be buying
the most expensive purses for sure.
- If you have the money and
if it makes you feel good,
then awesome.
- Just make sure you have good taste
because some of that expensive
(beep) looks like (beep).
- Purses are dumb.
- Why don't people learn
to make their own purses?
How hard could it be?
They don't even look nice either.